aquí dibujé un triángulo arbitrario y
etiquete las medidas de sus ángulos
internos con tres letras x y y ceta lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
mostrar que la suma de las medidas de
los ángulos internos de cualquier
triángulo es decir x + ye maceta siempre
es igual a 180 grados y para eso vamos a
utilizar nuestros conocimientos acerca
de rectas paralelas y de ángulos
correspondientes déjame empezar
extendiendo este segmento el que es
opuesto al ángulo z para formar una
recta para hacer algo así sale ahí
tenemos la recta que resulta de extender
este segmento ok el siguiente paso va a
ser construir una paralela a esta recta
que pase por este vértice de acá
y para eso simplemente lo que tenemos
que hacer es empezar en este vértice y
empezar a recorrer hacia allá y hacia
acá por aquí ya la tengo preparada deja
la pongo nos quedaría algo de ese estilo
sale entonces tenemos que esta recta
azul déjame indicar que es paralela a
esta recta roja de acá vale bueno ya
teniendo estas dos rectas paralelas
ahora vamos a necesitar algunas
transversales entonces déjame cual voy a
hacer ahora déjame trazar la recta que
resulta de prolongar este segmento de
acá vale el queso opuesto al ángulo en
que entonces nos quedaría algo más o
menos de ese estilo y ya teniendo dos
rectas paralelas y una recta transversal
podemos empezar a pasar algunos ángulos
verdad por ejemplo este ángulo de acá
que mide x es correspondiente con este
ángulo de acá verdad entonces este
ángulo de acá también mide x
y como este ángulo es opuesto por el
vértice a este de acá este ángulo
también mide x todo está en grados vale
x grados de grados iceta grados vamos a
hacer exactamente lo mismo con el otro
lado que nos falta prolongar es decir
vamos a tomar este segmento y lo hacemos
una recta nos quedaría algo de este
estilo vale entonces ahora esta recta
verde la podemos pensar como una
transversal a la recta roja y a la recta
azul y con eso podemos pasar algunos
otros ángulos por ejemplo este ángulo en
que ahora es correspondiente a este
ángulo de por acá a este ángulo de aquí
entonces déjame marcar que también me
deje y este ángulo y si nos fijamos en
la recta azul y la recta verde es
opuesto por el vértice con este de acá
entonces el de este lado también mide y
muy bien ya casi terminamos nuestra
prueba ahora observa que este ángulo que
mide x y este que mide z son adyacentes
de modo que si los junto para hacer este
ángulo blanco de aquí la medida va a ser
la suma de la medida de estos dos es
decir ese ángulo blanco que acabo de
marcar mide x más z más z
muy bien pero observa este ángulo blanco
es suplementario con este ángulo de acá
el que mide y porque entre los dos
forman la recta azul la recta que
construimos paralela a esta de acá de
modo que la suma de sus medidas debe ser
igual a 180 grados y eso es
prácticamente lo que queremos verdad
déjame apuntarlo por acá para que veas a
qué me refiero tenemos que el ángulo
blanco o la medida del ángulo blanco que
es x maceta maceta más la medida de este
ángulo de acá el ángulo rosa que mide y
es igual a 180 grados a 180 grados
porque justo forman este ángulo de acá
verdad déjame marcarlo en color pues no
sé en color naranja este ángulo de acá
este ángulo de acá y esto es exactamente
lo que queremos si quieres puedes
reacomodarlo un poco pero eso ya es
básicamente lo que estábamos buscando la
medida de este ángulo de acá o sea x más
la medida de este ángulo de acá y más la
medida de este ángulo de acá z es igual
a 180 grados justo como queríamos
mostrar